Coffee at 4:00
AM on a Saturday night and blog 28,
and so tonight we are on the set of my
very good friend,
Nolan as new short film Motel Blues.
Tonight we're filming at the pear
blossom motel up about 60 miles north of
Los Angeles and we have the whole motel
rented out for the night,
which by the way is one of the coolest
things about independent filmmaking and
filmmaking in general is that you get to
use real locations like this and
repurpose them for your movie.
Tonight I want to show you what goes
into making a short film of this stature
and one thing you should understand is
that the only difference between this
and a movie you might see at your local
AMC is the amount of money in the
budget.
The way this film is being made is the
way all films are made.
A big budget blow.
It might have,
you know,
more people on the crew,
more freedom with time and locations and
equipment,
but all the necessary stuff is here and
it's left like all films to the actors.
The story,
the filming techniques and the vision of
the director,
but let me,
let me introduce you to the quick.
Let's.
Okay,
so first we had the unit production
manager or ups whose job it is to manage
the production from before the filming
to after upm will create a working
budget before principal photography and
do her level best to make sure that the
final cost,
it doesn't go too much over the mark on
smaller productions.
The UPM is also responsible for hiring a
casting agent as well as anyone else the
crew might need.
In short,
this person's sails the ship as calmly
as she can to ward principle photography
when the assistant director or add
assumes the job as onset organizer 80
maintains order on the set as hooligans
from every department and run this way
and that to arrange the shot,
the 80 rights and sends out call sheets
which are scheduled for the days of
shooting and the 80 calls out
necessarily commands before the shot
starts.
It sounds sort of like this.
Roll audio roll camera.
Next we have the sound record is quite
possibly the most overlooked,
underrated,
and important job on an indie film set.
It's difficult to communicate just how
much sound determines the way we
perceive a movie.
Filmmaking gets branded as largely a
visual medium,
but poorly recorded.
Sam can destroy an otherwise great
project to record good sound,
good dialogue,
which means recording all the many
frequencies of the human voice.
The record is used as a boom or lavalier
mic to get as close to the actors'
mouths as possible.
This requires coordination with the DP
and the director,
making sure that they set up the shot so
that the recorders can position his mic
close,
but at a frank.
Next we have the and his assistant.
The best board.
These gentlemen are responsible for
lighting a movie and as a film is
essentially a combination of light and
darkness.
They're responsibility is huge.
Film lighting is exceedingly tricky
because the camera lens sees differently
than the I and the gaffer must
understand that often irrational
relationship between the two.
When you have a talented one like our
friend Justin here who can work quickly
to produce stunning images,
you simply put up with his embarrassing
personality,
Colby,
Jack.
Next we have hair and makeup and the art
director.
Hair and makeup is responsible for
making the accurus look good and the art
director has that same responsibility
for the set.
The Art director can take an otherwise
blend space and create the appropriate
mood with furniture,
trinkets,
whatever he can find.
There's nothing and art director likes
more than a thrift store full of other
people's throwaway junk.
Next we have the assistant camera
people,
those quiet warriors who serve as the
third,
fourth,
fifth,
and sixth,
the hands of the DP.
The Camera Department must assemble the
camera,
attach it to whatever tripod or rig will
be used for the shot and question and
perform that daunting and also under
appreciated task.
No,
as focus pulling,
see a camera lens can only focus on one
cross section of space away from the
camera.
It being a larger small cross section,
depending on the lens and the light,
if either the actors where the camera is
moving during the shot,
the noble focus puller must buy soft
adjustments of the Lens,
make sure the talent stays within the
given cross section or depth of field.
It's like a game.
The most infuriating game ever created,
all the work done by the gaffer.
His assistant and the camera department
is done to satisfy the demands of the
director of photography or DP,
working closely with the director and
being his first partner.
The DP determines the shot,
how it will be lit,
how the camera will move,
what the framing will be,
all in an effort to serve the needs of
the story.
Everything a camera does is felt by the
audience and the DEP must understand and
manipulate the rules of composition that
we might feel what the story wants us to
feel.
The DP directs our attention to what we
need to see.
The other job of the DP always make the
actors look good.
The of supply,
the human element to it felt they take
written characters and make them real
for the audience to love or hate
whatever the story demands.
They are subservient to the director,
but often is the case that actors being
students of human behavior find a way to
present their characters which the
director would never have thought of in
which in fact serve his ends better.
It's important therefore to give actors
freedom to find what's real in the
dialogue and action written for them.
After all,
the audience will never see the script.
They will see the actors and nine times
out of 10,
the performances are what they'll be
talking about on the car ride home and
finally we get to the most important
part of a film.
The part on which everything else
hinges.
Craft services,
yes.
Where the food is.
It's perhaps impossible to say what a
film shoot can become if the crew is not
satiated.
It starts with whispers of maltreatment.
Wines and backtalk sharp attitudes and
chatting.
Before you know it,
someone is throwing a one k at the
director's head for goodness sakes.
Feed your crew if it's possible,
spoil them.
The respect and quality work you'll get
in return will be worth it.
And lastly,
the director there will fill,
might sometimes start it's journey to
the theater at the pen of a
screenwriter,
and though in unhappy circumstances it
may end its journey with the discretion
of a producer.
There was no question that the artist of
a film,
the one whose vision the rest are trying
to realize is the director in its purest
form.
A director plays all the parts I just
mentioned that of writer director and
trump card holder in large budget
pictures.
This is rarely the case and there have
been plenty of fine films made in that
system,
but the characteristic quality of low
budget film,
especially no budget short films,
is that necessity requires that the
director does indeed play all these
parts,
including that of the editor.
Here.
We really get to see what's in the
filmmakers heart and how he translates
it to the screen.
The no escaping slaves like I can be
submerged and God bless America.
God bless America right.